[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the sec commissioner greg sankey
back on the program
home stretch there greg who would have
thought all those times we were talking
over the summer
now you can come clean full disclosure
how nervous were you that you were going
to get in a full
season when we were speaking back in the
summer
um you know do our best but uh
you know no there were never a guarantee
dan and so i've talked about hold your
breath
moments which is covid testing i mean
every week has been a challenge it is
been wearing
but we're close we're not quite there
we're close though
and uh testing results today are
negative
which is positive for playing this
weekend
you get updates every every week on
every school three times
three times a week um so we have a
conference managed testing program
through a third party
in football it's sunday tuesday thursday
and those results will will trail either
that evening or the next morning so i
started the season
if like friday was my hold your breath
moment
as you waited to see if people get on
the plane because we wanted to test
before people traveled to avoid some of
the
the controversies we've seen in other
circumstances
and then as you know we played three
weeks uninterrupted which may be the
greatest accomplishment this season
we had seven games for three straight
weeks and then just got into this cycle
of
of disruption and and all of a sudden my
hold your breath moment on friday
was monday morning when we were waiting
for testing results because we had some
some disruption of curly in the week and
again on wednesday and then on friday so
it's been a constant
constant cycle of uh i don't know if
it's worry concern attention
focus on will we be able to play games
what was your reaction to the latest
college football playoff rankings
well obviously i have an sec perspective
and and i think we
set ourselves up with a 10 game schedule
that has been recognized over time as
incredibly rigorous even when it's eight
um and even with records that may not be
what people anticipated it is still
difficult to win games in the
southeastern conference i think
the committee recognizes the quality of
football here so
you know for the top eight um certainly
encouraging but there's still football
to be played
what changes would you make to the
process
the selection process yeah well let's
let's just remember 2020 is an
odd year um like i would love to have
played non-conference games in football
but we needed to move those early so we
could then play a conference schedule
that wasn't the mindset that was shared
so
the fact we had to play conference only
in many circumstances in fact the most
is one that was out of my control i i
think the first change is
just me make sure we have quality
non-conference competition
in football because that gives you this
scale
um are there other metrics that could be
used i don't know that i go there so now
what i watch is the reaction from
yesterday is well the bcs was better
you know it didn't have these humans
making decisions when we had the bcs
it's like ah these polls are nonsense we
need humans
in the room making decisions but what
about expanding to eight
i don't think eight solves anything from
my perspective it
you know we're gonna be arguing about
nine we have an agreement
uh to start with four in a playoff
that's what happened in 2014 a set of
objectives
we can't go too long my coaches have
told me in fact coaches and other
conferences that played in the
championship game have told me when you
got to the end of that
your team was done and there's a
physical toll
that's taken so the give and take is
is bigger than just go to eight and
eight has implications
you know my friend jim delaney one time
said and i think it's okay to share this
because i think it's he's
spot on when we only had two teams
selected for a national championship and
you weren't in it
the the impact on your brand or the
esprit de corps of your conference
wasn't that large
when it went to four and you're left out
that's a bigger deal
and i've certainly felt that pressure um
you go to eight
what are the outcomes there um is that
the right number i just don't go to
eight in my mind automatically as the
solution
has ohio state passed the eye test
um i don't watch them much so
you're going i'm the wrong person to ask
because
i'm immersed in what happens here that's
why i'm not on the selection committee
explain to me florida loses at home to a
subpar lsu team and only drops one spot
well subpar to last year but you know
lsu has been
in close games and we play games because
you don't know what happens
and they've been embarrassed a couple of
times though greg they've been
embarrassed this year
well alabama's pretty good so you're
going to have to make a list of
people that have lined up against
alabama um
and and played well and you know what
dan part of
the challenge this year is the mental
challenge beyond the physical challenge
of playing football
the unknowns um the covet testing and
the results
opt outs who's left and what i've
watched
in a number of situations is when teams
get down to about 55
players they've started to play some of
their best football so that was an upset
but but let's be clear that's why we
play football games
it's competition you never know what
happens in a competitive
environment and you know last week some
people were probably uncomfortable when
i observed
we made a commitment to try to play
every game the covid
circumstances will dictate that and i
think that's the responsibility it needs
to be shared
is that a wwe belt over your shoulder
yeah can you yeah greg the commissioner
thank you can you get that
great can you go get that nick who
worked for us
in caa and that works for wwe sent me
that was like the
biggest smile i had all fall when i
opened up a package not knowing what it
was
can you go get that and bring it over
yeah i'll be happy yeah let me go look
at this i noticed that back there it's
like
nikon a famous agent and uh
you see that that's my apparently my
moniker and wwe world
you should wear that to the national
title game
well we've talked about that when it
showed up i walked around the office
and carried the cfp trophy in one hand
and wore the belt
i like it i like it i like it's like you
know these kids posing for the heisman
you know before
they get the heisman you know there's
nothing wrong with that you should
that's right
it's like a great talking point as we
found here this morning uh i know you're
short on time
and uh you gotta leave us but uh
congratulations so far you did a
wonderful job
uh and and uh you've allowed us to kind
of go
along with you the ride through this
process yeah so uh yeah
uh good luck in the sec title game
getting that and then uh whatever
happens in the final four greg thank you
very much
well thanks dan i've appreciated every
conversation you know some of the
questions
are uncomfortable but needed to be asked
right and sometimes i had to say you
know what i don't know but
uh problems yield to effort and we've
got a chance to crown a champion on
saturday and we've got three other games
scheduled too so
i think that's been a positive
experience it's been hard but it's been
a positive net thank you commissioner
yep greg sankey yeah he's
sec commissioner